PROFESSOR: Let's turn to
our next subject then.
So this is still time
dependent perturbation theory.
We will be doing time dependent
perturbation theory a little
longer, all of today's lecture
and a little of next time's
lecture.
So we're going to be talking
now about light and atoms.
So this is a classic
application of what time
dependent perturbation theory
does, the problem of radiation
interacting with atoms is more
and more detailed applications
and their ionization.
So light and atoms,
and we think one
of the situations we
will be considering
is a collection of atoms and
they're interacting with light.
But the way they
interact with light
is maybe not as controlled as
we had in hydrogen ionization,
in which you send in a wave.
But rather, it's
interacting with light
in thermal equilibrium.
So there's black body radiation.
There's all these photons,
unpolarized, in all directions,
coming at the atoms in all ways.
And they can produce
transitions in the atoms.
And for that purpose, we will
consider a collection of atoms.
And we will assume that
relevant to our situation,
we have two energy levels.
This state will be called b.
Still we'll call a, Ea and Eb.
So this is interacting
with light or with photons
at a temperature T.
So a little bit of
statistical mechanics today.
In order to discover
what Einstein did,
basically, we're going to go
through Einstein's argument
of balance of radiation
rates and emission rates
and things like that.
And we need to use some
statistical physics for that.
Einstein was very good at
using statistical physics.
And the frequency associated
with this transition
is Eb minus Ea over h-bar.
And we'll take it to
be greater than 0.
The state b will be considered
to be higher than the state a.
So the question we ask is,
what happens to these atoms
when light shines?
And in particular, suppose
the light contains photons
with a frequency omega b-a.
That's the frequency
associated with the transition.
So what will happen?
And basically, a couple
of things can happen.
These are things we
already know from time
dependent perturbation theory.
And surprisingly,
as we will see,
Einstein, when he went
through his argument
that we're going
to go through soon,
came with a different
angle and saw things
a little differently.
But let's follow
up the direction
that is based on the evidence
we've presented so far.
So there will be two
possibilities, two cases.
In the first case,
the atom is initially
with its electron on
level a, electron in a.
So what happens?
Well, we've coupled, a system
with two levels, two harmonic
perturbations.
And we saw that sometimes the
particle or the system goes up
and sometimes goes down.
And now we're going to see
the source a little bit more
realistically.
Before it was a perturbation.
Now we're going to
identify the perturbation.
The electron is in state a.
And here comes photons.
And what's going to
happen is a process
of absorption of the photon.
And the electron
goes to state b.
So we'll draw it here.
So this is before.
And here is after.
So before, you had this
thing and the electron
was on state a.
There was a photon coming
here with energy h omega b-a.
And then after, the
electron has been pushed up.
And there's no photon anymore.
The photon was absorbed.
That's physically
what we would expect.
The other possibility is
associated to the process
of stimulated emission.
This is absorption.
And here we have
electron in b initially.
And we have stimulated emission.
And in this case of
the electron goes to a.
And another photon is released.
It's a very surprising
thing if you think about it.
And here, this is the
absorption process.
Now this stimulated
emission process,
you have the electron
originally in b.
And here comes the photon.
And the end result is an
electron in a and two photons.
We notice that, when
we're doing perturbation
theory between the
two energy levels
and we have the
harmonic perturbation,
we even notice the probability
to go from the bottom
to the top or going from
the top to the bottom
was the same in
perturbation theory.
And you would have
said, look, I understand
that when you have an
electron in the bottom level,
you need some energy from
the source to kick it up.
But why do you need this
source to make it go down?
It's just there.
It should go down by itself.
Well, you still need to couple
the system to something.
Because if you are in
an energy eigenstate,
you stay there forever.
The reason it goes
down is because it
couples to something.
And somehow, the coupling
through the electromagnetic
field helps this go down.
That's why it's called
stimulated emission,
because it's stimulated
by the radiation itself.
And so this doesn't seem
to play too much of a role,
but actually does, in
which just by the presence
of a photon at the
right energy difference,
it stimulates this to go down.
And now you have two photons.
So this is, of
course, something that
is used in technology a lot.
This is the principle of lasers.
And therefore, this discussion
of stimulated emission,
which was a lot due to Einstein,
is the idea of a laser.
So laser is Light Amplification
by Stimulated Emission
of Radiation.
So what do you need for a laser?
You need something that is
kind of a little strange
to begin with.
Because from the viewpoint
of statistical physics,
if you have a two-level
system, particles
will tend to be in
the lower level.
So why would they go here?
Well, they won't go
there by themselves.
That's the term called
population inversion.
You need to get
the electrons that
are in the bottom to
go up to the next level
and put them there.
That's a technical
difficulty, of course.
And it's usually solved
by optical pumping.
We are not going to be doing
engineering here today.
But there is a third level
here in a typical laser.
And you can send
the electrons, that
are sitting originally
here, with light
again into the third level.
And then it turns out
that that third level,
if you have the right atom, has
a transition to this level that
is rather quick.
So the electrons fall
here, fall very quickly.
And the lifetime of this
state here is very long.
So they pretty much stay there.
So this is the principle.
This extra level is sometimes
called the pump level.
And so this is done by optical
pumping, so optical pumping
to create population inversion.
That you get more states
in the upper state
than you would get in
thermodynamic equilibrium.
And then, you now have,
say, the levels here--
I'm going to draw them this way.
It makes it a little easier.
I think of one electron
here, maybe two here,
maybe four here.
And then comes a photon and
stimulates this electron
to go down.
And now you have two photons.
And they stimulate these
two electrons to go down.
And now they have four photons.
They can stimulate these
four electrons to go down.
Have now eight photons.
And that's the amplification
process of stimulation.
Each time you stimulate
one down, you achieve this.
In fact, technically speaking,
apparently in good lasers,
this transition
doesn't produce light.
You would say, oh, it
produces more photons.
But there's some
energy levels that
radiate by communicating
vibrational energies
to the atoms.
So apparently these transitions
are not electromagnetic.
And you don't mix more light.
So basically, stimulated
emission of radiation
is the thing that gets
this process going.
And that's what we're going
to try to understand now.
The whole discussion
that follows
and what we have to understand
about light and atoms
will make all this
quantitative and allow
us to produce numbers
and calculate rates.